It's summertime, and perhaps your thoughts have been drifting to your next vacation. Maybe you're dreaming of sitting on a beach with a cool drink in hand, or camping in the mountains, or exploring a new city, or just staying home for a week reading and binge watching TV. Whatever your idea of the perfect vacation, it's probably something that you look forward to all year. Do vacations actually make people happier in the long run? How do they affect our mental health and well-being? What about our physical health? And are some types of vacations more beneficial than others, and if so, which ones?
现在是夏天，也许你的思绪已经飘向了下一个假期。也许你正梦想着手里拿着冷饮坐在沙滩上，或者在山里露营，或者探索一座新城市，又或者只是待在家里读一周书、刷刷剧。无论你心目中的完美假期是什么样，它可能都是你全年所期待的事情。假期真的能让人长期更快乐吗？它们如何影响我们的心理健康和幸福感？对我们的身体健康又有什么影响？某些类型的假期是否比其他类型更有益？如果是的话，哪些更好呢？
Is it better to relax, to scurry around seeing new sites and expanding our horizons, or some combination of the two? Just how long do the benefits of vacation last? Is there anything you can do to make that post-vacation glow last longer? And finally, how do differences in work and vacation culture affect people's mental health and well-being around the world. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Sarah Pressman, a professor
是放松休息更好，还是四处奔波看新景点、开阔眼界更好，亦或是两者的结合？假期的益处能持续多久？你有什么办法能让假期后的那种愉悦感持续更久吗？最后，世界各地工作和度假文化的不同如何影响人们的心理健康和幸福感。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。首先是莎拉·普雷斯曼博士，她是加州大学欧文分校的心理科学教授兼副院长。
of psychological science and an associate dean at the University of California, Irvine. Her research focuses on the interplay between stress and psychological well-being and health. She has examined the role that positive emotions and behaviors play in influencing stress and health outcomes, and she's especially interested in understanding exactly how these positive factors get under the skin to influence our well-being. As part of that research, she's studied how vacations and leisure time affect people's stress levels and their physical health. Our second guest is Dr. Jessica de Blume, a work in organizational psychologist and a professor at the University of Groningen in the Netherlands. She studies the effects of vacation and leisure time
她的研究重点是压力与心理健康及身体健康之间的相互作用。她研究了积极情绪和行为在影响压力和健康结果方面所起的作用，她特别感兴趣的是了解这些积极因素究竟是如何深入人体内部来影响我们的幸福感的。作为该研究的一部分，她研究了假期和休闲时间如何影响人们的压力水平和身体健康。我们的第二位嘉宾是杰西卡·德·布鲁姆博士，她是一位工作与组织心理学家，也是荷兰格罗宁根大学的教授。她研究假期和休闲时间
on people's well-being and work performance, as well as how workers are being affected by the vanishing boundaries between work and non-work life today. She is an international scholar who previously spent five years living and working in Finland, and she's interested in differences in work and vacation culture in different countries and regions. Thank you both for joining me today. So happy to be here. Thanks for having us. Yeah, thank you very much. Great. So what exactly are the mental and physical health benefits of vacation? What have each of you found in your research? And maybe Dr. De Blum, we can start with you. Yeah, I started out from existing research, analyzing, of course, what has been out there already.
对人们幸福感和工作表现的影响，以及当今工作与非工作生活之间界限的消失如何影响劳动者。她是一位国际学者，曾在中国芬兰生活和工作过五年，她对不同国家和地区的工作与度假文化差异很感兴趣。感谢两位今天加入我的节目。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我们。是的，非常感谢。太好了。那么，假期的心理和身体健康益处究竟是什么？你们各自的研究发现了什么？也许我们可以从德·布鲁姆博士开始。好的，我从现有的研究出发，当然是分析了已经存在的研究成果。
And two very influential longitudinal studies found, like they investigated large groups, of healthy people. They medically examined them for 9 to 20 years in these different studies. And they both showed that not taking annual vacations was significantly associated with a higher risk for morbidity and even mortality due to heart attacks. So not taking holidays entails a health risk, you can say. And in my own research, I have approached this question from a slightly different lens, because I followed then people that take a vacation,
两项非常有影响力的纵向研究发现，他们调查了大量健康人群。在这些不同的研究中，他们对这些人进行了9到20年的医学检查。两项研究都表明，不休年假与心脏病发作导致的发病率甚至死亡率的风险显著增加有关。所以你可以说，不休假会带来健康风险。在我自己的研究中，我从一个稍微不同的角度探讨了这个问题，因为我追踪了那些休假的人，
and I followed them before, during and after their holidays, and tracked their well-being across that time period. And also there, I found that people's health and well-being, in this case, self-reported health and well-being, drastically increased right when they go on the holiday. It remains quite high in the middle part of the holiday, and then vanishes very quickly or goes back to baseline once they are back at work. So within two weeks, levels of work engagement, burn out, and so on go to baseline levels.
我追踪了他们休假前、休假中和休假后的情况，并记录了他们在那段时间内的幸福感。同样在那里，我发现人们的健康和幸福感，在这种情况下是自我报告的健康和幸福感，在他们去度假时急剧增加。在假期中期保持在相当高的水平，然后一旦他们回到工作中，这种感觉就会很快消失或回到基线水平。因此，在两周内，工作投入度、倦怠感等水平就会回到基线水平。
Dr. Pressman, does that resonate with you? What is your research found? Yeah, absolutely, it resonates. And, you know, we've been looking more recently, especially at the cardiovascular outcomes that Dr. de Blum mentioned, you know, really monitoring people's cardiovascular function while they go through vacation, both before and after. And what we really see is that, you know, when we look physiologically at what's happening their body, not just these like serious outcomes, but, you know, how is that happening? And we monitor their heart rate or their blood pressure. What we see is that as people start anticipating their vacation, even the weeks before,
普雷斯曼博士，这与你的研究结果一致吗？你的研究发现了什么？是的，绝对一致。而且，你知道，我们最近更多地关注了德·布鲁姆博士提到的心血管结果，你知道，真正监测人们在度假期间，包括度假前后的心血管功能。我们真正看到的是，你知道，当我们从生理学角度观察他们身体发生的情况时，不仅仅是这些严重的后果，而是，你知道，这是如何发生的？我们监测他们的心率或血压。我们看到的是，当人们开始期待假期时，甚至在假期前的几周，
you start seeing those benefits. People, their stress is bothering them less. And what that means is that, you know, when they feel these kinds of negative emotions and anxiety and worry, it's not having the same kinds of implications for their body. body. And we know that that's true for not just, you know, long, serious vacations. I know we're going to get to what kind of vacations help, but even just leisure. When we engage in, you know, gardening, when we engage in hobbies over the weekend, these things also seem to have the same benefits in reducing our blood pressure, reducing our stress hormones. And these should lead to
你就会开始看到这些益处。人们的压力对他们的困扰减少了。这意味着，你知道，当他们感受到这些负面情绪、焦虑和担忧时，这对他们的身体并没有产生同样的影响。我们知道，这不仅适用于那些漫长、严肃的假期。我知道我们稍后会谈到什么样的假期有帮助，但即使只是休闲。当我们参与园艺，当我们周末从事爱好时，这些事情似乎也有同样的降低血压、减少压力荷尔蒙的益处。而这些应该会导致
benefits to our physical health, you know, just like Dr. de Bloom was saying, you know, it should lead to differences in mortality and longevity and disease outcomes. Well, let's talk for a minute about the different types and lengths of vacations. I want to ask whether the health benefits of staycations where people don't go anywhere, are they as robust as those of actual vacations that involve getting away from your home? I think I can really speak to the research that Dr. Pressman was already mentioning that we indeed also see that in our studies coming back. We had people, we followed people, that had a domestic holiday, so that was four or five days in their home country,
对我们身体健康的益处，你知道，就像德·布鲁姆博士所说的那样，你知道，这应该会导致死亡率、长寿和疾病结果的差异。好吧，让我们花点时间谈谈不同类型和长度的假期。我想问一下，人们不去任何地方的“宅度假”的健康益处，是否像那些需要离开家去度假的假期一样稳固？我想我可以谈谈普雷斯曼博士已经提到的研究，我们确实在我们的研究中也看到了这一点。我们追踪了那些在国内度假的人，也就是在他们本国待了四五天，
so Netherlands in this case. And we also followed people that just had a regular weekend. And we could see there very similar patterns that also during weekends, during regular leisure time, people did recover, did report higher health and well-being levels, engaged in activities that they greatly enjoyed. So also there, we can see that. we did see a little bit different types of activities because at home you're maybe more likely to engage in chores or things that are not only enjoyable like houseworks, domestic work, taking care of young children family members that can also be exhausting. And that is maybe a bit harder in the home context to deal with that and also to get this mental detachment from work because our laptop may be potentially with us in the weekends and we may simply open.
在这种情况下是荷兰。我们也追踪了那些只是度过了一个普通周末的人。我们可以在那里看到非常相似的模式，即在周末，在正常的休闲时间里，人们确实得到了恢复，确实报告了更高的健康和幸福感水平，从事了他们非常喜欢的活动。所以同样在那里，我们也能看到这一点。我们确实看到了一些不同类型的活动，因为在家里，你可能更容易从事家务或不仅仅是享受的事情，比如家务活、家庭琐事、照顾年幼的孩子和家庭成员，这些也可能让人精疲力竭。在家庭环境中处理这些问题，以及从工作中获得这种心理脱离可能有点困难，因为我们的笔记本电脑在周末可能就在我们身边，我们可能只是打开它。
open it and start working. So that's the challenge of a staycation, I would say. Yeah. And it's really, I think, you know, pros and cons of staying home versus going away because obviously we know that travel is full of so many stressors, right? You know, security at airports, possible illnesses along the way, packing, the cost of it, things going wrong. And so there are so many things that you lose control over when you're traveling, especially to far away locations that you don't have with a staycation. But just like we heard from Dr. Bloom to Bloom, you know, there are also these consequences of staying home. And so you have to kind of weigh the pros and cons, I think, and think about, you know, I think how long is your vacation going to be? Are you going to be able to kind of get
打开它就开始工作。所以我认为这就是“宅度假”的挑战。是的。而且我认为，你知道，待在家里和外出度假各有利弊，因为显然我们知道旅行充满了许多压力源，对吧？你知道，机场安检、沿途可能出现的疾病、打包行李、费用、事情出错。所以当你旅行时，尤其是去遥远的地方，你会失去很多控制权，而“宅度假”则不会有这些问题。但就像我们从德·布鲁姆博士那里听到的那样，你知道，待在家里也有这些后果。所以我认为你必须权衡利弊，并考虑，你知道，我认为你的假期会有多长？你能够克服
over the travel stress so that you can truly enjoy yourself and relax in the place that you're going to? Because obviously going away has benefits. I mean, you might experience awe because there'll be novelty, which is a great positive emotion with a lot of benefits to physiology and health. And you might experience, obviously, more, you know, social bonding when you're away from your daily life and the grind. And so there are so many benefits to going away. But I think that you have to balance that against the stress and make sure that you're able to really enjoy your vacation if you do go away. Well, speaking of enjoyment, if I could ask another question, what about the people who don't really unplug during vacation, the people who take their phones and their laptops,
旅行压力，以便你能在要去的地方真正享受自己并放松吗？因为显然外出度假有好处。我的意思是，你可能会体验到敬畏感，因为会有新鲜感，这是一种非常有益于生理和健康的积极情绪。而且当你远离日常生活和繁重工作时，你可能会体验到更多的社交联系。所以外出度假有很多好处。但我认为你必须在压力之间取得平衡，并确保如果你真的外出，你能够真正享受你的假期。说到享受，如果我可以问另一个问题，那些在度假期间并没有真正“断电”的人，那些带着手机和笔记本电脑的人，
and they basically continue working while they're on vacation. Do they get the same health and well-being benefits as people who completely unplug? We also ask people that in our study how much time they spend on work-related activities during their holidays. We had phone interviews with them during the holiday. And we did find that quite a share of people did engage, some clients with colleagues and so on, but they all said that this was their own choice, and they could also decide the amount of time they would spend on it. And in this scenario, then we didn't see the negative effects.
他们基本上在度假时继续工作。他们能获得和那些完全“断电”的人一样的健康和幸福感益处吗？我们在研究中也问过人们在假期中花多少时间在与工作相关的活动上。我们在假期期间对他们进行了电话采访。我们确实发现相当一部分人确实参与了，比如与同事联系等等，但他们都说这是他们自己的选择，他们也可以决定花在上面的时间。在这种情况下，我们没有看到负面影响。
And it was on average, I think, half an hour that people spent during the holiday on work-related activities. And then we don't see the negative effects. What we see from other research or from Sabina Sonantag and colleagues, for instance, that this mental disengagement from work is really crucial to have that on a regular basis to really recover and, yeah, get your physiological system to baseline levels and to rewind. Dr. Pressman, are there strategies that people should use in order to actually unplug during vacation? I mean, maybe you really feel like you've got to look at your email, but what can you do to keep it under control? I mean, it's a great question.
平均而言，我想人们在假期中花半小时在与工作相关的活动上。在这种情况下，我们没有看到负面影响。我们从其他研究或萨比娜·索南塔格及其同事的研究中看到，例如，这种与工作的心理脱离对于定期进行这种脱离以真正恢复，是的，让你的生理系统回到基线水平并重新充电是非常关键的。普雷斯曼博士，人们应该采取什么策略来真正地在度假时“断电”？我的意思是，也许你真的觉得你必须查看电子邮件，但你能做些什么来控制它呢？我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题。
And I think, you know, it does depend on how you perceive your work, whether or not you should do this, right? Because I think for some people, the unplugging could be more stressful than not unplugging. And, you know, and if you do love your job and, you know, it's going to be worse for you not to do it. You know, that could be consequential. But if you really do need the break, because like we heard just now, it is critical for us to actually restore. You know, there are so many things that you can do, right? You can leave your phone in your hotel room. Don't bring it with you.
而且我认为，你知道，这确实取决于你如何看待你的工作，无论你是否应该这样做，对吧？因为我认为对某些人来说，“断电”可能比不“断电”压力更大。而且，你知道，如果你确实热爱你的工作，而且，你知道，不这样做对你来说会更糟。你知道，那可能会产生后果。但如果你真的需要休息，因为就像我们刚才听到的那样，我们实际上需要恢复是非常关键的。你知道，你可以做很多事情，对吧？你可以把手机留在酒店房间里。不要随身携带。
You can turn on an away message. There is a great trend that I've seen with people putting on fabulous away messages on email that really says, you know, I'm not really checking my email. Like, this is not something I'm doing, you know. Or, you know, put blocks on your phone, right? You can block your email. You can put so that maybe you only spend a certain amount of time or certain hours of the day. You're only going to look at it. And I think, you know, there's great technology.
你可以开启自动回复。我看到一个很好的趋势，人们在电子邮件上设置了很棒的自动回复，真正写着，你知道，我真的没有在查看我的电子邮件。就像，这不是我正在做的事情，你知道。或者，你知道，在你的手机上设置拦截，对吧？你可以拦截你的电子邮件。你可以设置，这样也许你只花一定的时间或一天中的特定时间。你只会在那个时间查看它。而且我认为，你知道，有很棒的技术。
because of the overwhelming, you know, interference of technology right now and the constant distraction we have, companies really have stepped up to create a lot of programs to help us, you know, take a break. And so I think you just have to commit to that seriously and, you know, promise yourself that you will give yourself a true break. Is that kind of a cultural thing? I mean, I know in America, we don't take our vacations. We may be given two weeks of vacation that we just feel we can't possibly take because, oh, my God, something is going to happen. I'm going to miss out at work. I'm just not going to get my next promotion. My boss is going to know that I was away for too long. I mean, whatever the guilt factor is.
因为现在技术带来的压倒性的干扰，以及我们面临的持续分心，公司确实已经加强了力度，创造了很多项目来帮助我们，你知道，休息一下。所以我认为你只需要认真对待这一点，并且，你知道，向自己承诺你会给自己一个真正的休息。这是一种文化现象吗？我的意思是，我知道在美国，我们不休假。我们可能被给予两周的假期，但我们觉得我们根本无法休假，因为，天哪，会发生什么事。我会错过工作。我不会得到下一次晋升。我的老板会知道我离开太久了。我的意思是，无论负罪感因素是什么。
Is that a particularly American thing? Dr. de Blum, are you seeing that in other cultures as well? I do see it in other cultures as well. I also have worked quite a lot with Japanese colleagues. There we also see long working hours. There's even a word for dying from overwork. So it's also a serious problem there. And also in Europe, I think I would say it's increasingly common to respond to emails outside regular working hours. And burnout is becoming like a batch of honor, right? Like as a sign that you have done your best. And I think that's very problematic. And in itself, you can question whether working hours is a good measure of actually performing and doing your best.
这是一种特别的美国现象吗？德·布鲁姆博士，你在其他文化中也看到了吗？我在其他文化中也看到了。我也和日本同事一起工作过很多。在那里我们也看到了长时间的工作。甚至有一个词是形容“过劳死”的。所以这在那里也是一个严重的问题。而且在欧洲，我想说，在正常工作时间之外回复电子邮件也越来越普遍。倦怠正在成为一种“荣誉勋章”，对吧？就像是你已经尽了最大努力的标志。我认为这非常有问题。而且本身，你可以质疑工作时间是否是衡量表现和尽力的好标准。
but that seems to be our only way nowadays to show our ambition or one of the few ways to easily show motivation and ambition. So, yes, I think it's all around the world. You can see it. But, yeah, maybe American culture is maybe a little bit more extreme than the average European working culture. You talked a little bit about staycations and short respites from your everyday work, but can a vacation be too long? Dr. Pressman, I see you smiling. You
但这似乎是我们如今展示雄心壮志的唯一方式，或者说是容易展示动力和雄心的少数方式之一。所以，是的，我认为全世界都是这样。你可以看到它。但是，是的，也许美国文化比一般的欧洲工作文化稍微极端一点。你刚才谈到了一些关于“宅度假”和日常工作中的短暂休息，但假期会太长吗？普雷斯曼博士，我看到你在微笑。你
have an answer for that one? I really don't know the answer to that. I'm curious if Dr. de Blume does because I haven't seen a study that asked that question. I mean, you know, I can imagine, obviously, if you're a working adult, you know, the stress is going to start increasing the longer that you're away. And, you know, we know that for some people, when they get back to work, it can be worse. You know, like if the stress and you haven't kept up with things and, you know, there's a million emails in your inbox that you have to deal with and that there's things that you were supposed to do that you didn't do. That's obviously going to create, you know, it's going to potentially wash out the benefits of the vacation when you get back.
有答案吗？我真的不知道答案。我很好奇德·布鲁姆博士是否知道，因为我没有看到过问这个问题的研究。我的意思是，你知道，我可以想象，显然，如果你是一个工作的成年人，你知道，你离开的时间越长，压力就会开始增加。而且，你知道，我们知道对某些人来说，当他们回到工作岗位时，情况可能会更糟。你知道，比如如果压力很大，你没有跟上进度，你知道，收件箱里有一百万封邮件需要处理，而且有些事情你本该做却没做。这显然会造成，你知道，这可能会在回来时抵消假期的益处。
And so I think that it could be too long if you're not accounting for those factors. But, you know, if the norm is, and obviously in some cultures, the norm is we take summers off or we take a month off in the summer and that's what everyone is doing, I think that that's going to, you know, potentially prevent that kind of harm at least. But I'm very curious to hear what Dr. de Blume has to say to see if she knows. Is there the ideal number of days of vacation? Do we know that? We don't. Because it's actually really hard to investigate because people tend to take the amount of holidays that works best for them. And you could think of setting up a research project in which you assign people to certain vacation duration or vacation location, but then
所以我认为如果你没有考虑到这些因素，假期可能会太长。但是，你知道，如果常态是，显然在某些文化中，常态是我们夏天休假或者夏天休一个月，每个人都这样做，我认为这会，你知道，至少有可能防止那种伤害。但我非常好奇德·布鲁姆博士怎么说，看看她是否知道。有没有理想的度假天数？我们知道吗？我们不知道。因为这实际上很难调查，因为人们倾向于选择最适合他们的假期长度。你可以考虑建立一个研究项目，将人们分配到特定的假期时长或度假地点，但随后
you also can really wonder what kind of people do you attract for these studies. So it would never render very good results, I think. So that makes it very hard to investigate the duration. But overall, we do not see this dose response relationship that you would maybe expect that the longer the holiday, the longer lasting the effects are. So what I think more and more when I look at research on vacations, but also on shorter respites from work, think of breaks, lunch breaks and so on, that I think the regularity and having a regular breakout times, that's maybe much more important than having a long time out.
你也可以真正怀疑你会吸引什么样的人参加这些研究。所以我认为这永远不会产生很好的结果。这使得调查持续时间变得非常困难。但总的来说，我们没有看到你可能预期的那种剂量反应关系，即假期越长，效果持续时间越长。所以我认为当我观察关于假期的研究，以及关于工作中较短休息的研究，比如休息时间、午餐时间等等时，我认为规律性和有规律的休息时间，这可能比长时间的休息更重要。
It reminds me also of the holidays in the Nordics, which is also maybe to do with the light that they tend to have quite long summer holidays because when, yeah, enjoy the sun and the sunshine and the light while it lasts. I can totally understand that. But there's always the risk when you do that and you put all eggs in one basket and then maybe this one holiday doesn't turn out as good as you hope because maybe the weather is really bad or the location is absolutely not what you're expected or you get sick during the holiday. Then, yeah, you feel very bad about it. And also you don't have enough other respites throughout the year. There are some companies in the U.S., and perhaps overseas, I'm not fully aware of this,
这也让我想起了北欧的假期，这可能也与光照有关，他们倾向于有相当长的暑假，因为当，是的，享受阳光和光照，趁它还在的时候。我完全能理解这一点。但当你这样做，把所有鸡蛋放在一个篮子里时，总是有风险的，也许这个假期并没有像你希望的那样好，因为也许天气真的很糟糕，或者地点绝对不是你所期望的，或者你在假期期间生病了。那么，是的，你会对此感到非常糟糕。而且你全年也没有足够的其他休息时间。美国有一些公司，也许海外也有，我不太了解，
but some companies in the U.S. have said, you have unlimited vacation. As long as you do your job, you can go off for six months and trek in the Himalayas if you want to. Are people doing that? I mean, have you looked at any of this and does it have any impact or people just still too afraid to take that much time away from their jobs? Yeah, we're actually in the process of doing a research project on unlimited leave policies. And so far we have written a more conceptual piece on that together with my colleagues. And our ideas and also what we take from research is that on the one hand, you have this autonomy and this really nice feeling. And that's also what we learned from the first interviews we had.
但美国的一些公司说，你有无限的假期。只要你完成工作，如果你想去喜马拉雅山徒步旅行六个月，你可以去。人们在这样做吗？我的意思是，你研究过这些吗？它有什么影响吗？还是人们仍然太害怕从工作中抽出那么多时间？是的，我们实际上正在进行一个关于无限休假政策的研究项目。到目前为止，我和我的同事已经写了一篇关于这个问题的概念性文章。我们的想法以及我们从研究中得出的结论是，一方面，你拥有这种自主权和这种非常好的感觉。这也是我们从第一次采访中了解到的。
Like, okay, I have the freedom. I don't need to save up days because when needed I can always take off. So this feeling of freedom that really helps people, improves their well-being. But on the other hand, there are social processes like the one that we just discussed, that there's also a team that may be dependent on your work and that you don't want to leave alone. There are maybe people who are more easily argue and negotiate for their well-being and to have a longer holiday or to have a holiday during the busy summer season when everybody wants to be off.
就像，好的，我有自由。我不需要攒天数，因为需要时我总是可以休假。所以这种自由感确实帮助了人们，改善了他们的幸福感。但另一方面，存在着社会过程，就像我们刚才讨论的那样，还有一个团队可能依赖你的工作，你不想把他们单独留下。也许有些人更容易争论和协商他们的幸福感，并获得更长的假期，或者在每个人都想休假的繁忙夏季休假。
So there are these processes at the same time. So one process is the unleashing, or we call it the, yeah, you really can benefit from it. But then there's also the restricting process of people like the team being strict and restricting each other potentially. And that may lead to people taking actually less leave than they had previously when it was a fixed amount and everybody had the same. you have a norm to stick to. What about those people who spend their vacations viewing everything through the camera on their cell phone? Are they getting the same benefits as people who use their phones or other cameras a little more judiciously? Dr. Presbyn, any thoughts on that? No, I mean, it's a really interesting question. You know, there have been studies that have
所以同时存在这些过程。所以一个过程是释放，或者我们称之为，是的，你真的可以从中受益。但随后还有限制过程，比如团队变得严格，并可能相互限制。这可能导致人们实际上比以前固定天数且每个人都一样时休假更少。你有一个需要遵守的规范。那些在度假时通过手机摄像头观看一切的人呢？他们能获得和那些更审慎地使用手机或其他相机的人一样的益处吗？普雷斯曼博士，有什么想法吗？不，我的意思是，这是一个非常有趣的问题。你知道，已经有研究
used smartphones as a way to savor. And so if you're not familiar with the concept of savering, It's really being in the moment, really trying to experience something positive and lengthen how long it affects you. And so, you know, typically with savoring, we do that by, you know, meditating on it or just trying to be in the moment. But there have been studies where they say, oh, well, you should take a picture of it so that you can remember it and, like, recall it and take it. So I think it doesn't have to be a bad thing. But what we also know is that having your phone with you all the time, I mean, it's not just the taking the picture, right? It's the fact that you're going to get notifications and that you might go on social media. And so there's other things that are taking out of the moment besides the photograph, right?
使用智能手机作为一种“品味”的方式。所以如果你不熟悉“品味”这个概念，它实际上是活在当下，真正试图体验一些积极的东西，并延长它影响你的时间。所以，你知道，通常在品味时，我们通过，你知道，冥想它或只是试图活在当下。但已经有研究说，哦，好吧，你应该拍一张照片，这样你就可以记住它，并且，比如，回想它并带走它。所以我认为这不一定是一件坏事。但我们也知道，一直带着手机，我的意思是，不仅仅是拍照，对吧？这是因为你会收到通知，而且你可能会上社交媒体。所以除了照片之外，还有其他事情在把你从当下带走，对吧？
And so I actually had an interview recently with someone who was really interested in this phenomenon where some people are turning back the clock and using flip phones. So like the old fashion, like, you know, from 10 years ago, maybe even longer than 10 years ago, you know, pre-smartphone kinds of phones for this exact reason, because they want to be in the moment. they want to not be distracted. They don't want to be searching the internet for everything. And so I think, you know, Kim, like you said, I think that for some people it is a problem, right? That they're unable to be in the moment and really take in the positive experience that they're having
所以我最近确实采访了一个人，他对这种现象非常感兴趣，有些人正在倒退，使用翻盖手机。就像老式的，你知道，10年前，甚至可能比10年前更久，你知道，智能手机之前的手机，正是因为这个原因，因为他们想活在当下。他们不想分心。他们不想为了每件事都在互联网上搜索。所以我认为，你知道，金，就像你说的，我认为对某些人来说这是一个问题，对吧？他们无法活在当下，真正吸收他们正在经历的积极体验
if they're distracted by what's going on. And certainly, you know, I do worry, you know, when you see people at a concert and the entire time they're filming, you know, are they really enjoying it as much? But I have mixed feelings about it because I think if you do film it, and you're able to keep reliving it over and over again, you're getting a positive emotion boost from that as well. And so I think you have to kind of figure out what's right for you. Are you able to still enjoy it while you're filming it? You know, I wouldn't want to lose that on a precious memory of my five-year-old because I didn't take a video of it, right? You know, so for some of us, it's like we want the ability to relive that over and over. And certainly with vacations, you may want to, you know,
如果他们被正在发生的事情分心了。当然，你知道，我确实担心，你知道，当你看到人们在音乐会上，整个时间都在拍摄，你知道，他们真的像那样享受吗？但我对此有复杂的感觉，因为我认为如果你确实拍摄了它，并且你能够一遍又一遍地重温它，你也会从中获得积极的情绪提升。所以我认为你必须弄清楚什么对你来说是正确的。你在拍摄时还能享受它吗？你知道，我不想因为我没有拍视频而失去关于我五岁孩子的珍贵记忆，对吧？你知道，所以对我们中的一些人来说，就像我们想要一遍又一遍地重温那种能力。当然，度假时，你可能想要，你知道，
if you see a whale swim by as you're out in the ocean, you know, you might regret not taking a picture of that. And so I wouldn't want people to not document because they're worried of not being in the moment. Yeah, and maybe to add to that, this social element is maybe also an important one, that it's also possible then to share your experiences with people that are not with you at the moment, but that enjoy the memory with you at the moment. We talked a little bit earlier about how long that after vacation glow lasts. what's a typical time frame once you've come back to your regular life for you to still feel the benefits of, oh, the relaxation, the fact that I had a great time? And then you get back into the grind.
如果你在海洋中看到鲸鱼游过，你知道，你可能会后悔没有拍下那张照片。所以我不想让人们因为担心没有活在当下而不记录。是的，也许补充一点，这种社交元素可能也是一个重要的因素，即那时也可以与此时此刻不在你身边的人分享你的经历，但他们可以和你一起享受那一刻的记忆。我们之前谈到了假期后的那种愉悦感能持续多久。当你回到正常生活后，你还能感受到那种放松、那种我度过了一段美好时光的事实，通常的时间框架是什么？然后你又回到了繁重的工作中。
How long does the glow last? Do we know? Yeah, I'm very short. I can tell. So in the studies that we have done and we looked at domestic holidays for five days, we looked at winter sports holidays of a week. average and on a long holidays, like three weeks on average. And they all had similar effects in terms of like in the first week after returning home from the holiday, they were back to how they felt before, which was also good, right, because they are healthy employees and happy with their job. But yeah, that's about the lasting benefits in terms of health and well-being, right?
那种愉悦感能持续多久？我们知道吗？是的，很短。我可以告诉你。所以在我们所做的研究中，我们观察了五天的国内假期，我们观察了平均一周的冬季运动假期，以及平均三周的长假。它们在效果上都有相似之处，比如在度假回家后的第一周，他们回到了度假前的感觉，这也是好事，对吧？因为他们是健康的员工，对工作感到满意。但是，是的，这就是关于健康和幸福感的持久益处，对吧？
but I think there are much more effects that we didn't capture that do last. And then I'm thinking, for example, my colleague does research on couple experiences, and they see that couples do engage more actively with each other and their relationship when they are on holidays. And those effects, they will persist also after the holiday or the family memories that you create together. There's research on backpackers, like young people who maybe take a really long time and go backpacking through the world. And they say that it really changes their view on themselves, give them new perspectives on the world. This is not something you catch when you ask people about the actual health and well-being at the moment. Are there strategies for extending that happy feeling to something that you can do when you come home that maybe would extend it?
但我认为还有很多我们没有捕捉到的效果确实持续了。我想，例如，我的同事对夫妻体验进行了研究，他们看到夫妻在度假时确实更积极地与对方和他们的关系互动。这些效果在假期后也会持续，或者你们一起创造的家庭记忆。有关于背包客的研究，比如年轻人，他们可能花很长时间在世界各地背包旅行。他们说这确实改变了他们对自己的看法，给了他们看待世界的新视角。当你问人们当下的实际健康和幸福感时，这不是你能捕捉到的东西。有没有什么策略可以把那种快乐的感觉延伸到你回家后可以做的事情上，也许能延长它？
Pressman? Well, I was going to say one thing that we saw in a recent paper from a few years ago is that there are some people who that benefit does last for a few weeks for, but it's people who, I mean, to put it colloquially, I think, have a good job. So the people who have a job with high effort, reward imbalance, where they're putting in a lot of effort but not really getting a lot back, those people, it's just like Dr. De Bloom was saying, like, those benefits are gone right away. They don't get much of a benefit for long. But the people who don't have those kinds of jobs actually did see a few weeks of well-being benefits, which at least says that there's something there going on with stress and your experience at work. But I mean, as far as thinking about this from like a broader
普雷斯曼？嗯，我想说的是，我们在几年前的一篇论文中看到的一件事是，有些人那种益处确实持续了几周，但这些人是，我的意思是，通俗地说，我认为，有一份好工作的人。所以那些工作努力与回报不平衡的人，他们投入了大量努力但并没有真正得到很多回报，这些人，就像德·布鲁姆博士所说的那样，那些益处立刻就消失了。他们没有得到太多的长期益处。但那些没有那种工作的人确实看到了几周的幸福感益处，这至少说明压力和你在工作中的体验确实有某种联系。但我的意思是，就从更广泛的角度来思考这个问题而言
psychological experience, you know, how do we lengthen our positive experiences? You know, how do we make them last longer? I think a really important thing is, is, you know, like we were just talking about before, you know, trying to relive these experiences and savor them, you know, not forget this great experience that you had. Sharing it with other people is a great way to savor an experience, you know, show your, I mean, it might be obnoxious for some, but, you know, showing your photos to other people, you know, talking about it, you know, reliving it with the person that you were with so that you get those micro doses of positivity that are going to help reduce the stress that you're experiencing. So I think that's a big part of it,
心理体验，你知道，我们如何延长我们的积极体验？你知道，我们如何让它们持续更久？我认为一件非常重要的事情是，你知道，就像我们刚才谈到的，你知道，试图重温这些体验并品味它们，你知道，不要忘记你拥有的这段美好经历。与其他人分享是品味体验的好方法，你知道，展示你的，我的意思是，对某些人来说这可能很讨厌，但是，你知道，向其他人展示你的照片，你知道，谈论它，你知道，与你在一起的人重温它，这样你就能获得那些有助于减少你所经历的压力的微量积极情绪。所以我认为这是其中的很大一部分，
is not letting the vacation go just because you came back, you know, trying to, you know, we know that right now there's a lot of research that's showing the anticipatory benefits of good things, not just in vacation, but anything, a concert, any kind of positive experience. You know, it's not just the concert or the vacation that gives us happiness. It's the weeks leading up to it that really have this, you know, fade in anticipatory glow. And so why can't we try to do that on the way out as well, right? can we try to think back on it positively, you know, try to keep that positive emotion going for as long as possible. Yeah, and maybe I can add to that the research by my colleague Dr. Jana Kuno.
就是不要因为你回来了就让假期结束，你知道，试图，你知道，我们知道现在有很多研究显示了对美好事物的预期益处，不仅仅是在假期，任何事情，音乐会，任何种类的积极体验。你知道，不仅仅是音乐会或假期给了我们快乐。而是导致它的几周，确实有这种，你知道，预期的愉悦感。所以为什么我们不能在结束时也尝试这样做呢，对吧？我们可以尝试积极地回想它，你知道，尝试尽可能长时间地保持那种积极情绪。是的，也许我可以补充一下我的同事贾娜·库诺博士的研究。
She looked at this, what she calls the fade-out process of these effects and found that when people had high work demands after returning home, the effects fade even quicker. and that relaxation in the evening hours after work could buffer and could help to extend the effects. So that would speak to trying to have a slow work start and not, I think what many of us do is we come back from the holiday. There's a pile of work, our inbox is totally overflowing, and we want to get it done within the first day of working. And then we make long hours because we feel energized and we feel like, okay, we have to energy. to do it, but that actually really wears the effect out very soon. So the trick could be researchers have found that if you start on a Wednesday, for example, and have like a shorter first working week that could help to slow down this process
她研究了这个，她称之为这些效果的“淡出过程”，发现当人们回家后有很高的工作要求时，效果消失得更快。而下班后晚上的放松可以缓冲并有助于延长效果。所以这说明要尝试有一个缓慢的工作开始，而不是，我认为我们许多人所做的是我们从假期回来。有一堆工作，我们的收件箱完全溢出了，我们想在工作的第一天内完成它。然后我们工作很长时间，因为我们感到精力充沛，我们觉得，好的，我们有精力。去做它，但这实际上确实很快就磨损了效果。所以诀窍可能是研究人员发现，如果你在周三开始，例如，有一个较短的第一个工作周，这可能有助于减缓这个过程
and to help keep the demands low and the relaxation levels high. How much does the vacation locale matter when it comes to people's, the effect on people's mental and physical health? Doesn't matter if people go on a city vacation where they see a lot of museums and, you know, go out to dinner and the theater, or whether they go to the mountains or whether they go to the beach or a lake. Does that make a difference in the overall effect on people? I can, I mean, I don't think anyone has really, you know, like we were talking before, you can't randomize someone to go to a city versus go to a beach. People are going to pick the things that are good vacations for them. And so I think a lot of that is no. knowing what's going to restore you, right? Is are you someone who needs culture? Are you someone who the Broadway show is going to bring you the most joy?
并有助于保持低需求和高放松水平。当涉及到人们的心理和身体健康影响时，度假地点有多重要？如果人们去城市度假，看很多博物馆，你知道，出去吃晚餐和看戏，或者他们去山里，或者他们去海滩或湖边，这重要吗？这对人们的整体效果有影响吗？我可以，我的意思是，我不认为有人真的，你知道，就像我们之前谈到的，你不能随机分配某人去城市还是去海滩。人们会选择对他们来说是好假期的东西。所以我认为很多都是，知道什么会让你恢复，对吧？你是那种需要文化的人吗？你是那种百老汇演出会给你带来最大快乐的人吗？
Or are you someone who just needs the peace and, you know, quiet of vacation by the beach or in the mountains? I will say that there's a huge body of literature on nature as restorative. You know, there's so much work on green spaces and blue spaces and how they not only reduce stress, but, you know, physiologically, they're having changes on us. us. They re-energize us. People often feel more energized after spending time outside. You know, lots of things are happening to our bodies. And, you know, psychologically, we're just, you know, calmer, happier when we're in nature. You know, we can really, there's all sorts of great interventions now. You know, you don't obviously have to go on a vacation to get this. You can just go on an awe walk where you really try to take in everything around you or, you know, just really unplug in
还是你是那种只需要海滩或山里假期的平静和安静的人？我会说，关于自然作为恢复性资源有大量的文献。你知道，关于绿色空间和蓝色空间有太多的工作，以及它们不仅如何减轻压力，而且，你知道，在生理上，它们对我们有改变。它们让我们重新充满活力。人们在户外度过一段时间后通常会感到更有活力。你知道，我们的身体正在发生很多事情。而且，你知道，在心理上，我们只是，你知道，当我们身处大自然中时更冷静、更快乐。你知道，我们真的可以，现在有各种各样的伟大干预措施。你知道，你显然不必去度假就能得到这个。你只需要去进行一次“敬畏漫步”，在那里你真的试图吸收你周围的一切，或者，你知道，只是真正地在
the moment and even that alone can give you like a little micro vacation from that. But that's not to say that, you know, if Disneyland's your thing or Disney World's your thing, that you're not going to get a lot of joy from that and that you're not going to have a wonderful vacation. I think you just have to know what's going to work for you and what you need. Yeah, maybe I can add to that, that we looked at different activities that people engage in. And we didn't find strong links to the effects that people have, probably because exactly what Dr. Pressman was explaining, people choose what's good for them. What we could see is that we look also at recovery mechanisms.
当下“断电”，即使仅仅是那样也能给你带来一点小小的假期。但这并不是说，你知道，如果迪士尼乐园是你的菜，或者迪士尼世界是你的菜，你就不会从中获得很多快乐，你就不会有一个美妙的假期。我认为你只需要知道什么对你有效，你需要什么。是的，也许我可以补充一点，我们观察了人们从事的不同活动。我们没有发现与人们所受影响的强烈联系，可能是因为普雷斯曼博士解释的正是这一点，人们选择对他们有益的东西。我们能看到的是，我们还观察了恢复机制。
There's a model that has been developed also by Sabina Sonnetag in her group. That has, like for example, the mental disengagement I was mentioning, the relaxation, also being in control, deciding yourself, how you want to spend your time. Or mastery, for example, having a pleasant challenge that you undergo that that can help to increase the benefits of the holiday and get more out of it, so to say. And that I think that's pretty independent of the place. You could potentially have these experiences in any environment, create those. And some, it's maybe easier than in others. Yeah. And I think one important ingredient, too, is who's with you. You know, when we've done work on
有一个模型也是由萨比娜·索内塔格和她的团队开发的。它有，例如，我提到的心理脱离，放松，还有掌控感，自己决定你想如何度过你的时间。或者精通，例如，经历一个愉快的挑战，这有助于增加假期的益处并从中获得更多，可以这么说。我认为这与地点相当独立。你可能在任何环境中都有这些体验，创造这些体验。而且有些，可能比其他更容易。是的。而且我认为一个重要的成分也是，谁和你在一起。你知道，当我们做过关于
leisure activities independently to look at which leisure is most beneficial to your health and your physiology, the social activities seem to give you a little bit more bang for your buck. You know, if you're having meals with other people, if you're engaging in hobbies with other people, that does seem to be beneficial a little bit more, at least in the leisure perspective of doing things by yourself. And this echoes all of the push, you know, from the Surgeon General right now, the United States on, you know, the health impact of loneliness and how critical social relationships are to longevity and health. And so I think there's a big part of that, that, you know, vacations give us a to engage in our relationships in a way that we don't when we're working and we're going through
独立休闲活动的研究，以观察哪种休闲对你的健康和生理最有益时，社交活动似乎能给你带来更多的回报。你知道，如果你和其他人一起吃饭，如果你和其他人一起从事爱好，这似乎确实比你自己做事情在休闲角度上更有益。这呼应了美国卫生局局长目前关于孤独对健康的影响以及社会关系对长寿和健康有多关键的所有推动。所以我认为这其中有很大一部分，你知道，假期给了我们一种方式来参与我们的关系，这是我们在工作和经历时所没有的。
the daily grind. And so I think highlighting, you know, the opportunity to really capitalize on your positive relationships and build them and really connect with people is going to have a big, a big impact as well. What about people who have kids? Is it better to take the kids with you or leave them with grandma and grandpa? That depends on the kids, I would say. I just remember years of vacationing with my parents. We'd sit in the backseat of the car screaming at each other the whole time when we were driving up and down the east coast of the U.S. I don't know how my parents did it, but does it have an impact?
日常琐事。所以我认为，强调利用好积极的人际关系并建立联系，确实会产生巨大的影响。那么有孩子的人呢？带孩子一起去度假更好，还是把他们留给祖父母照顾更好？我认为这取决于孩子。我记得我小时候和父母一起度假的那些年，我们开车往返于美国东海岸时，全程都在后座大喊大叫。我不知道我父母是怎么忍受过来的，但这有影响吗？
I mean, I will say anecdotally from as a parent of a young child, you know, a lot of people who have young children, I think that they don't call vacations vacations. They call them trips when they're taking their kids with them, right? It's basically babysitting in a different location. And so, I mean, I think it's a really hard question because, you know, when we talk about the relationship piece we were just mentioning, you obviously want the vacation as an opportunity to build your relationship with your child. You know, it's an opportunity to have memories that will last forever that you can go back and savor. You know, these things should build positive emotions and social connections that are good for you. But, you know, parents are also burnt out and exhausted. we had the pandemic years where people had no child care for years. I mean, I think if people have the
我的意思是，作为一名幼儿的家长，我从个人经验来说，很多有小孩的人，他们不会把度假称为“度假”。当他们带孩子一起去时，他们称之为“旅行”，对吧？这基本上就是在另一个地方看孩子。所以，我认为这是一个非常棘手的问题，因为正如我们刚才提到的关系层面，你显然希望度假能成为增进与孩子关系的机会。这是一个创造永恒记忆的机会，你可以回味这些记忆。这些经历应该能建立起对你有益的积极情绪和社会联系。但是，父母也感到精疲力竭。我们经历了疫情时期，人们好几年都没有托儿服务。我的意思是，如果人们有
I mean, I don't know of research on this. I will say, you know, this is totally conjecture. But, you know, if you had a place where you wouldn't be stressed leaving your kids, you know, either it's a vacation where there's child care or there's a grandparent who's going to take them off your hands, I mean, I think that all parents deserve a break. And so I think if there's a way to do that in a way that doesn't stress you out, at least sometimes that's certainly going to be beneficial for from a restoration perspective to actually have a true break where you're not just babysitting. You mentioned the pandemic. What do we know about what's happening now that the pandemic has been declared over? I mean, is this going to be a year of everybody's wildly going on vacation or have
我不知道这方面的研究。我只能说，这完全是推测。但是，如果你有一个地方可以让你放心地把孩子留在那儿，比如有托儿服务的度假地，或者有祖父母帮你照看，那么我认为所有的父母都应该得到休息。所以，如果有一种方式能让你在不感到压力的情况下做到这一点，至少有时这从恢复的角度来看肯定是有益的，能让你真正得到休息，而不是仅仅在换个地方看孩子。你提到了疫情。既然疫情已经宣布结束，我们对现在的情况了解多少？今年会是每个人都疯狂去度假的一年吗，还是
people gotten into a rut of not taking vacation, got used to staying home? Maybe we're going to do that again this year. Yeah, I don't know the exact numbers. I'm not a tourism researcher, but my impression from what I see around me is that people got to appreciate the things close by more. And I see people that do say now, instead of flying somewhere and having all the travel stress that we were mentioning before, plus sustainability issues coming up, maybe it's as nice to just go half an hour somewhere and go camping in nature somewhere and do something that does take us in a different environment,
人们已经习惯了不度假，习惯了待在家里？也许今年我们还会那样做。是的，我不知道确切的数字。我不是旅游研究人员，但我从周围看到的情况来看，人们开始更加欣赏身边的事物。我看到有些人现在说，与其飞到某个地方，承受我们之前提到的所有旅行压力，再加上日益突出的可持续性问题，也许去半小时车程的地方露营，在大自然中做点什么，换个环境，也同样美好，
but still without all the hassle of traveling far. And that also reminds me a little bit of this slow travel movement that has also now been investigated a little bit, that it showed that when people, the distance, the actual distance cover doesn't really matter for the feeling of being away, but it's more the time it takes to go. to get there. So when you would go by bike or maybe take the train, take a slower mode of transportation, you can feel away from home while still being relatively close. So I think that's
而且不需要长途旅行的麻烦。这也让我想起了现在受到一些研究的“慢旅行”运动，研究表明，当人们旅行时，实际覆盖的距离对于“远离家乡”的感觉并不重要，重要的是到达那里所需的时间。所以，当你骑自行车或乘火车，选择一种较慢的交通方式时，即使离家相对较近，你也能感受到远离家乡的氛围。所以我认为这
a nice way of thinking about it and rethinking maybe where we want to go. And I think it probably also, it relates to the individual differences we were talking about before with people's differences in where they want to go on vacation. I think that now we saw in the U.S. at least, huge surges in the number of people booking flights last summer, right? So this has really been a huge increase since the pandemic. But it's not everybody. I mean, I think there are people who, maybe the more introverted people, maybe the people who don't have as much of a need for novelty, aren't sensation seekers, you know, so there's like these personality differences where I think some people really suffered during the pandemic because they weren't going away. And other people
是一种很好的思考方式，也许可以重新思考我们想去哪里。我认为这可能也与我们之前讨论的个体差异有关，即人们对度假地点的偏好不同。我认为，至少在美国，我们看到去年夏天预订航班的人数激增，对吧？所以自疫情以来，这确实有了巨大的增长。但并不是每个人都这样。我的意思是，我认为有些人，也许是更内向的人，或者对新鲜感需求没那么高、不是追求刺激的人，他们确实存在这种性格差异。我认为有些人因为不能外出而在疫情期间感到非常痛苦，而另一些人
were like, you know, maybe I can just rent an Airbnb an hour and away. And that feels just as good. And, you know, I think the climate changed thing is really also having a big impact. I've seen a lot fewer people, at least in academics, going to conferences for that reason, where, you know, maybe because of the pandemic, you know, they're realizing that the state of our planet is really important. And if they can do small things, you know, then they don't need to maybe travel quite as much as they used to. So what are the big questions that you both want to answer through your research?
则觉得，也许我可以在一小时路程外租个爱彼迎（Airbnb），感觉也一样好。而且，我认为气候变化的影响也确实很大。至少在学术界，我看到因为这个原因去参加会议的人少了很多，也许是因为疫情，他们意识到地球的状况非常重要。如果他们能做一些小事，那么他们可能就不需要像过去那样频繁地旅行了。那么，你们两位希望通过研究回答哪些重大问题呢？
What are you looking at now? Dr. de Blum, let's start with you. Yeah, this project on unlimited leave I was briefly touching upon. I think this really is high on my research agenda to understand these processes that make people on the one hand feel this freedom, this flexibility. But at the same time also sometimes resulting in self-exploitation or not taking off anymore or not taking good care of yourself. And so understanding why this happens, how it happens, and also how you can prevent that on a more systemic level as a company, as a team, as a leader, what role do all these elements play in making it work? Because I think in fact, I like the idea of flexibility and giving autonomy, but we somehow need to create boundary conditions that really help to make it beneficial for everyone. Dr. Pressman, what are you looking at now?
你们现在在关注什么？德布鲁姆博士，我们先从你开始。是的，我刚才简要提到的关于无限期休假的项目。我认为理解这些过程确实是我研究议程中的重中之重，这些过程一方面让人们感受到这种自由和灵活性，但另一方面有时也会导致自我剥削，或者不再休假，或者不再好好照顾自己。因此，理解为什么会发生这种情况，它是如何发生的，以及作为公司、团队或领导者，如何在更系统的层面上预防这种情况，所有这些因素在使其发挥作用方面起什么作用？因为我认为，实际上，我喜欢灵活性和赋予自主权的想法，但我们必须以某种方式创造边界条件，真正帮助它对每个人都有益。普雷斯曼博士，你现在在关注什么？
You know, my big interest has always been how do we protect ourselves against the harms of stress and really being able to give people advice that is targeted to the context that they're living in. And so I would love it if we could figure out better, you know, depending on what's going on in your life, what is the best vacation for you to take or what is the best thing that you could do in terms of even, you know, how you spend your time off on a daily basis. you know, what's the right advice? You know, and especially the thing I've gotten very interested in is energy from a psychological perspective, which I know Dr. Dubloom is doing some work on as well. Because I think that that's something the pandemic has triggered is our own psychological energy
你知道，我一直非常感兴趣的是我们如何保护自己免受压力的伤害，并真正能够为人们提供针对他们所处环境的建议。因此，如果能更好地根据你生活中的情况，找出最适合你的度假方式，或者即使在日常生活中如何利用休息时间，找出你能做的最好的事情，那将是再好不过了。你知道，什么是正确的建议？而且，我特别感兴趣的是从心理学角度看“能量”，我知道德布鲁姆博士也在做这方面的研究。因为我认为这是疫情引发的问题，是我们自身的心理能量
crisis where I think we're all just feeling more depleted than we ever had. And so trying to understand that better in terms of how do we help people feel more vigorous and energized in their day-to-day life, be it how they spend their time off or how they spend their day-to-day. I think that's a really critical question right now. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. I think the bottom line for our listeners is take your vacations. It's good for your health, your physical health, and your mental health. I want to thank you both for re-emphasizing that. And I hope you both have some nice vacation in your futures, too. Thank you so much. Thank you very much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychicizing
危机，我认为我们所有人都感到比以往任何时候都更加枯竭。因此，试图从如何帮助人们在日常生活中感到更有活力和精力充沛的角度来更好地理解这一点，无论是通过他们如何利用休息时间，还是如何度过日常生活。我认为这是目前一个非常关键的问题。好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我的节目。我认为给听众的总结是：去度假吧。这对你的健康，包括身体健康和心理健康都有好处。我要感谢你们两位再次强调这一点。我也希望你们未来都能有愉快的假期。非常感谢。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或苹果、Spotify、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。
on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan.
如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。我们的音效编辑是克里斯·孔达扬。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。